hey it's PlayStation's mid-month update
time again a boatload of games are added
to the catalog and whether you're on the
extra or premium tier which is also
called Deluxe I've got you covered with
a bit of gameplay I'm Adam hello there
please help us out and recommend a game
coming to PS Plus in August 2023 first a
quirky family game for the summer moving
out two releases on August 15th and
straight into the PS plus extra catalog
we run a removals company and must get
everything on the van as quickly as
possible it then becomes apparent that
this is not a simulation we can smash
through Windows use pool umbrellas as
trampolines and generally treat every
item with little to no care at all
moving out 2 can be played in Solo couch
Co-op or online with friends and if the
original game is anything to go by
things escalate quickly to include some
weird and wonderful objectives
definitely worth your time on PS4 and
PS5 PlayStation's purchase of Bungie has
led to another Destiny DLC being made
free on Playstation Plus this time it's
the witch Queen first released in
February last year the free to play
first person shooter relies heavily on
paid expansions which continually add
missions raids and story events to the
ever-expanding world the witch Queen is
the sister of oryx and another servant
of the worm God but instead of all-out
attacks she uses trickery and
misdirection to get the upper hand and
also lots and lots and lots of minions
no not those ones Destiny remains a
great shooter so will you jump back in
hold up a minute the game you've all
been waiting for without realizing is
coming lawnmower simulator Landmark
Edition on a quick note this does not
drop on the 15th this arrives in the
catalog on the 28th of August as it's an
updated version of the game which is
already on PS plus extra if I remember
correctly The Landmark Edition includes
DLC like a Dino Safari what a time we
live in there's one more game that isn't
arriving at the same time as the others
because on August 29th sea of stars is
here and joined PS plus extra on day one
the highly anticipated blah blah blah
blah blah blah the highly anticipated
retro style RPG is a prequel to 2018 to
the messenger which got many perfect 10
out of 10 reviews which is why sea of
stars is so sought after the story is
centered around Heroes that learn to
harness the power of the Sun and the
Moon to solve puzzles and take part in
turn-based combat which then leads into
finding Elemental weaknesses of enemies
we are told sea of stars is littered
with side quests a cool sailing mechanic
and combat challenges and don't worry if
you haven't played the messenger sea of
stars is set a thousand or so years
earlier and is giving me Chrono Trigger
Vibes sea of Stars August 29th next a
more serious game for you lost judgment
officially a Yakuza side project that
brings the world of a crime detective to
the series we play as takayuki Yagami
who once was a lawyer but now is a
street level detective willing to get
his hands dirty sent to investigate a
crime with no leads at all he somehow
finds a way way to crack the case and
crack a few skulls too because this guy
can fight fans of the Yakuza series
should definitely pick up lost judgment
and rest assured it has all the crazy
silly side quests and activities that
make Yakuza games so iconic reviews make
lost judgment hard to place with highs
of 9.2 out of 10 and lows of 6.5 so it's
one of those where you have to try it to
know for yourself over on the PS4 we
have two Point Hospital jumbo Edition a
business Sim set in a cartoony world
with bizarre conditions patients find
themselves with like light-headedness
which is literally a light bulb on
someone's head that needs to be
unscrewed the focus of all this is about
money and turning a profit while
expanding the hospital to bring in more
patience with more ailments it honestly
builds up to be quite stressful if you
employ the wrong staff because some will
fall asleep at their desks after two
years the Metacritic score remains over
80 so it's definitely one you should add
to your list next Destroy All Humans 2
reprobed comes to PS plus extra this
month as we do exactly what the title
suggest guests the alien Invader crypto
returns this time during The Swinging
60s and we take revenge on the FBI for
blowing up our Mothership the original
action adventure game released in 2006
and now I feel old anyway the Remake is
remarkably close to the original check
out another insane idea for a game
cursed to golf a sports roguelike let me
set the scene we are a golfer who is hit
by lightning and wakes up in purgatory
luckily there is a way back home by
completing an 18-hole course by staying
under par but each life causes a restart
we then slowly upgrade our gear and
stats until we can complete the course
and return to the land of the living I
love this concept Golf and a roguelike
in one Metacritic currently is 74 out of
100. another roguelike which is a little
more standard is source of Madness set
in a Twisted lovecraftian inspired World
the game learns your playstyle and
adapts to suit or hinder it constantly
rooms are procedurally generated making
every playthrough completely different
hopefully they're actually doing quite a
few interesting things which could
change how games are made in future in
source of Madness so maybe it's time to
take the role of the new Acolyte and
embark on a nightmarish Odyssey and look
here dreams is here again you have this
already it's in your monthly games for
essential subscribers but if you you
forgot to download it it's here anyway a
game about making games I won't dwell on
this but I do think Sony missed the
chance to grow the Audience by leaving
dreams off PS Plus for so long for the
sprogs in your life this month we have
PJ masks Heroes of the night on PS4 and
PS5 and Hotel Transylvania scary tale
Adventures I've got to admit I have not
played these I'm totally clueless if
they're worth your time but I do know
they are both action Platformers so
enjoy and rounding off the month is
stealth Boss 3 refost on the PS4 an RPG
crossed with a real-time strategy game
and lastly midnight fight expressed on
PS4 is a Fight Fest which to me is like
an approachable version of sifu with
more firearms and things to grab this is
quite an indie game and to really
demonstrate that is how brutal the
action is in this game it's not for the
week of heart to be honest the story is
pretty good too from trying to escape
our criminal past we end up dragged
straight back in again Metacritic
currently has this around 76 alas as
games are added to PS plus extra some
are taken away it's your last chance to
play the following games before they go
to sleep for a while on Tuesday the 15th
of August Borderlands 3 is the first
person shooter with some of the greatest
and weirdest and wonderful guns in
gaming it's your last chance to get your
fill of that also three Yakuza games are
going zero kiwami and kawami too races
will lose the crew too grip and
Carmageddon Max damage and it's time to
say goodbye to 8-bit Army's DC Elva game
and the magnificently underrated nidhog
be sure to play any that take your
fantasy before update day on August 15th
and to end the video the unreliable
mixed bag that is PS Plus premium or
Deluxe sometimes iconic sometimes
horrendous and this month see for
yourself medieval Resurrection from the
PSP era joins us and reviewed around six
to seven out of 10 back then of course
it doesn't really live up to Modern
standards but you get the idea ape
Escape on the loose is a much loved
classic from all the way back in 2005
and pursuit Force extreme Justice is a
great crime action game jumping from car
roof to car roof dodging bullets like
you're in a Michael Bay movie I love
that game back then for PS Plus premium
I'd say this is a good month what say
you okie dokie thank you very much for
your time please do me a favor and leave
a like and a comment that really helps
me get seen on YouTube I really
appreciate it so what are you playing
okay you've had enough of my voice I
understand I'll shut up now but before I
do go you should totally click on one of
these videos oh look that one's about
PlayStation games and this one's this
one I can't remember what this one's
about but I'm sure it's good
[Music]
thank you